Hi, I’m Hank Green, this is Crash Course,
and today I wanna explore two sites of knowledge
production in Europe during the medieval period.
This is the story of the cathedral and the
university.
[INTRO MUSIC PLAYS]
First, let’s agree to call the general time
period in Eurasia and North Africa after the
birth of large states
but before colonial empires the medieval:
a “middle age” that lasted from roughly
CE 500 to 1400.
So we've got our working definition established!
Across a large part of the medieval world,
people traded knowledge, and many folks practiced
different forms of humoral medicine and alchemy.
The majority of these explorations of nature
were conducted by individual elites—nobles
and other rich people who happened to take
an interest in the world around them.
In a few places, however, knowledge production
was highly centralized.
As we’ve seen in Baghdad, Delhi, Beijing,
and Bologna—lots of medieval people were
making knowledge systematically.
The north of Europe was a different story.
Until roughly 1100, there were relatively
few places of knowledge-making.
Monasteries and abbeys had special rooms called
scriptoria
where monks copied manuscripts by hand.
But the biggest places where knowledge was
made were the Gothic cathedrals.
Cathedrals were great stone churches that
took years, sometimes many decades to build.
They weren’t simply places to go on Sunday
to worship.
A cathedral was the seat of a bishop, or regional
church leader,
and the administrative, spiritual, and educational
center of the bishopric or diocese—the district
under the bishop’s control.
And if you wanted to go to one of these places,
that didn’t make you a christian, just like
going to taco bell doesn’t make you a taco.
And, unlike castles, cathedrals are still
used today for their original purposes.
Choosing a site for a cathedral was high stakes.
While secular rulers paid for cathedrals,
bishops often chose where to build them.
This redrew the map of Europe and made some
cities vastly more important: once a cathedral
was there, a city grew economically.
As populations grew, bishoprics split.
New cathedrals were needed.
While the first cathedrals date back to Constantine
the Great, the high age of cathedral building
lasted from roughly 1000 to 1500.
This was an era of frantic economic growth
in Europe.
The French, for example, built eighty cathedrals
between 1050 and 1350,
moving more stone for these projects, in total,
than was moved to build the great pyramids!
The construction of these vast, soaring spaces
required immense technical knowledge.
What made a cathedral such a technical wonder?
Help us out, ThoughtBubble:
The height of the cathedral was important:
narrow and tall, cathedrals drew the eyes
of worshippers up, inside and out.
Inside, a Gothic cathedral generally featured
spacious arched vaults, lots of narrow windows
casting light muted by stain glass, and a big round "Rose" window in the front.
Stained glass was not only an artistic achievement,
but a highly technical one.
Medieval artisans discovered through alchemical
experimentation that adding gold chloride
to molten glass resulted in a red tint, and
adding silver nitrate turned the glass yellow.
Recently, scientists analyzed stained glass
from this era and discovered that this technique,
possibly dating back to the tenth century,
worked because of nanotechnology!
Analysis of the stained glass revealed that
gold and silver nanoparticles, acting as quantum
dots, reflected red and yellow light, respectively.
Historians still have no idea how medieval
artisans made this glass.
Outside, towers and spires, guarded by gargoyles,
stood tall above the small buildings of the
medieval city.
Perhaps the most striking architectural feature
of the cathedral were its flying buttresses—
arches leaping off the side of the building,
distributing weight down, allowing the great
stone mass to move up and up.
The physics of flying buttresses reveals how
innovative they were.
High, stone-ceilinged cathedrals generated
heavy outward thrust, a force that had to
be directed safely down to the ground.
Added to this was the problem of strong winds,
which presented a danger to the tall, skinny
bodies of cathedrals.
One solution would have been to make the walls
of cathedrals gigantic and thick and ugly.
But that’s not what the cathedral builders
did!
To move thrust out and down and resist the
wind, buttresses were connected to the main
building with arms, making them look as though
they were “flying.”
Capped by intricately carved pinnacles, these
arched supports allowed much light to stream
in through the stained-glass windows.
They also used less stone, reducing the cost
of materials and labor.
Thanks Thought Bubble!
This strategy worked pretty well for many
cathedrals…
Although the one at Beauvais—with an incredibly
tall choir and a slightly misaligned arched
vault—partially collapsed in 1284.
For the most part we do not know who designed
the cathedrals.
But we know that economic opportunities in
cathedral cities attracted many skilled artisans.
Each cathedral project was led by a master
builder.
Rough masons cut, mortared, and laid the heavy
stones.
Freemasons completed the more intricate work,
such as the tracery around the rose windows.
These artisans were the engineers of medieval
Europe.
And having large numbers of them move from
location to location was very unusual for
a time when most people died in the same village
they were born.
These flying-buttressed monumental spaces
didn’t only motivate earthly activity.
They were representations of Paradise on earth.
This Paradise was part of a complex theoretical
system for answering the question “where
are we?”
The medieval Christian cosmos looked a lot
like the Aristotelian–Ptolemaic one: an
earthly sphere bounded within a series of
planetary spheres, and beyond that, an ultimate
heavenly sphere.
But this heaven was literally Paradise, the
home of God.
And below the earth was Hell.
(Dante strikingly detailed this Christianized
model of the Aristotelian cosmos in his Divina
Commedia.)
You might wonder why the medieval Christians
were so obsessed with death and Hell…
Well, we don’t want to accuse medieval Europe
of having been some uninteresting “dark age."
But it could be a pretty rough time and place
to be alive.
A striking example of this grimness is the
Black Death, a plague that swept across Europe
from 1348 to 1350.
Perhaps spread by flea-ridden merchants traveling
the Silk Road, the plague bacterium, Yersinia
pestis,
killed anywhere from 75 to 200 million people—which
was 30 to 60 percent of Europe’s total population,
in two years.
aaaaahhhhh...
And the plague came back periodically until
the nineteenth century… when cholera pandemics
arrived!
Before the Black Death, Europe had grown a
lot.
And it was during this pre-plague period that
universities took off.
Between 1100 and the mid-1300s, population
growth and urbanization led to rise of the
university: there were more secular conflicts,
so they needed more lawyers.
There were more religious arguments, so they
needed more theologians.
And there were more people—and more were
sick!—so they needed more physicians.
The proto-university in Europe was Charlemagne’s
palace at Aachen or Aix, in what is now Germany.
Charlemagne and his successors centralized
knowledge production at the palace.
From around 800 until about 855, Aachen was
an important site for the production of manuscripts
including religious and legal texts.
The first true European universities included
Salerno, Bologna, Padua, and Naples in Italy;
Oxford and Cambridge in England; Paris and
Montpellier in France; and Valencia in Spain.
Still looking good, U. Salerno!
Eleven hundred is the new thirty.
Although they all feature impressive old buildings
today, medieval European universities started
off as self-governing associations of people
with a common function.
The places where those people taught and learned
could change, but the legal entity of the
university stayed the same.
In fact, the Latin word universitas even means "Corporation."
Which is... maybe... accurate today?
Joining this corporation required swearing a Christian oath.
University curricula, or book lists, had to
approved by the Church.
This was paradoxically freeing, though, because
it meant that cities and kings had to recognize
universities as self-governing:
if the Pope said that the faculty of a university
were cool with him, then kings and nobles
couldn't boss them around so easily.
They could teach and research what they wanted
to, as long as it was vaguely Catholic enough.
Plus, universities became tax exempt!
Let’s say we are well-off medieval students
ready to make campus visits.
First, our medieval parents lay out our options:
doctor, lawyer, or priest.
Those are real jobs.
If we can’t hack it at one of those, we
can instead study something called the “liberal
arts.”
Again, here we ware!
Traveling around, we encounter two kinds of
university: in the “Northern” model, such
as at Paris, the most important discipline
is theology.
The University of Paris was incorporated as
an association of these “masters,” or
teachers.
In the “Southern” model, at Montpelier
and the Italian universities, medicine and
law are the most important subjects.
These universities were incorporated as associations
of students, who had to pay the salaries of
their teachers.
No matter which school we choose, we’ll
need books.
Our Scholastic curriculum revolves around
a few core texts, including some names we’ve
already encountered:
the famous physicians, Aristotle—especially
the Physics—Euclid, Ptolemy, and Archimedes.
And did I mention Aristotle?
Which books we buy depends on what we’ll
study.
The artis liberalis, or liberal arts, are
divvied up into a group of three, the trivium—
or tools for thinking, which are grammar,
rhetoric and logic—and a group of four,
the quadrivium—or specific subjects,
which are arithmetic, geometry, astronomy,
and music.
If we decide to study medicine, we’ll read
and reread sayings attributed to Hippocrates,
Aristotle, Galen,
Ibn-Sina, Al-Razi, Ibn-Rushd and a few Latin writers—
maybe Trota and an amazing abbess named Hildegard
of Bingen.
She taught about human health as connected
to the “green” health of the living environment.
Hildegard was way ahead of her time!
Our teachers’ lectures serve as commentary
on the canonical texts.
And there is also some emphasis on learning
from experience—by visiting apothecaries,
shadowing doctors on their rounds, and attending
anatomical dissections… of criminals.
Dissection is everyone’s favorite class!
Although our liberal arts or medical curricula
are taught as more or less finished sets of
knowledge, this is not to say that no one
can make new knowledge.
It just has to enter the classroom as part
of an ongoing discussion with the long-dead
“masters.”
And enter it does.
By 1200, translations of classical Greek works
lost to the Latin- and Romance-speaking northwest
of Eurasia came back into the libraries of
universities and monasteries.
These were Latin translations of the Arabic
translations we mentioned back in episode
seven.
What was the result of all this book learnin’?
For one, medieval Christians had to work harder
and harder to reconcile scientific works by
their favorite Greek and Arabic masters with
a Christian worldview.
Increasingly, the faculty—thinking systematically
about thinking as separate from the Bible—ran
afoul of the Church.
In 1277, the bishop of Paris officially condemned
219 Aristotelian “errors,”
meaning that anyone teaching certain ideas
from Greek philosophies would be excommunicated.
Historians are split on how this affected
science: on the one hand, the suppression
of Aristotle’s ideas sounds bad.
But on the other, this condemnation freed
up medieval thinkers in continental Europe
to look beyond the so-called “masters.”
Thought experiments about how Nature might
really work, regardless of the Bible or Aristotle,
flourished.
Separating the study of a thing called “Nature”
out from that of a perfect God, even hypothetically,
helped set the stage for a secular scientific
program.
Nature became God’s delegate, an intermediary
force between God and humanity—something
to study… and, ultimately, control.
Control of nature meant first putting it in
the right order: head before toes,
first causes before final ones, universals
before specifics, and abstractions before
particulars.
This neat Aristotelian order, married to a
Christian interpretation of the world based
on scripture,
would soon come up against theories drawn
from meticulous record-keeping regarding natural
phenomena… such as astronomical data…
such as how heavenly bodies move…
But that’s for next time, when we’ll meet
a certain mathematician who attended four
great universities—
Krackow, Bologna, Padua, and Ferrara—Nicolaus
Copernicus!
Crash Course History of Science is filmed
in the Dr. Cheryl C. Kinney studio in Missoula,
Montana and it’s made with the help of all
this nice people and our animation team is
Thought Cafe.
Crash Course is a Complexly production.
If you wanna keep imagining the world complexly
with us, you can check out some of our other
channels
like Scishow Kids, The Art Assignment, and
The Financial Diet.
And, if you’d like to keep Crash Course
free for everybody, forever, you can support
the series at Patreon; a crowdfunding platform
that allows you to support the content you
love.
Thank you to all of our patrons for making
Crash Course possible with their continued
support.